Hey traders, it's my care and in this
video I'm going to talk about you know,
the importance of looking at more than
one or two markets, especially when
you're trading the order flow exhaustion
model. And you know, the reason for that
is because you know, sometimes you know,
the market's going to do what the
market's going to do, which is
facilitate trade, which is what it was
designed to do. So this is the minis.
It's about 10:20 this morning, 10:23 on
Tuesday, you know, the day after
Memorial Day and in the UK bank holiday.
So the markets
you know, had that abbreviated session.
And since the cash open there there
hasn't been any signals with the
exhaustion model, okay? And you know,
just going back here um you know, there
was there was one signal right ahead of
the cash open, couple you know, but
again, you know, that's 8:05, 8 uh
8:07. Um you know,
you know, cash is over you know, we've
had a long holiday, everyone's waiting
for the cash market to open. So that's
why you see the market just sort of
flatlining before the cash open in
bonds. Um again, you know, as this ultra
bonds rather, um no signals.
Now the currencies, currencies were
hopping today,
uh especially the euro. And with the
exhaustion model, there was uh there was
three trades.
Um basically, we had this one here
around 3:00 in the morning.
We had another one came in another
short, much better short coming in here
around 5:30. But uh just before 9:00,
8:55, we had a nice bullish signal that
came in.
Getting long right here, you know, it's
a move from about uh 16,033 gets up into
the 40s, just sort of hangs around, you
know, here for the next hour. So you
know, again, not the greatest trade, but
this one went was a beautiful trade
where it went from the high of the day
down to the low of the day. Okay?
But again, you'd have to be up at 5:30
in the morning. Um you know, another
market that I think is interesting that
gets overlooked, obviously, um just by
looking at the volume, it tends to be
overlooked is um mini Dow YM and you
know this is an interesting market. You
know I I used to like this market a lot
more in the past but the problem with it
is it's kind of thin, you know, I mean
most traders gravitate to MNQ or NQ than
YM but there are also nice trades to be
had. Now you know this is a $5 tick
and
you know so if you're getting you know
40 50 ticks that's you know 200 250 um
per trade. And this morning you know
there were some decent trades that could
have been had here. This was about uh
just before 10:00 at your exhaustion
signal here. Your entry is coming in
right here. Uh that puts it around 570
right in here. Does immediately just
shoot straight up over the next two bars
up above uh 600 gets up to around 610
but again you know maybe you can get out
around five you know at 60. But this is
one you know it moves around very fast.
You have to have
the ATMs shooting off as soon as you get
long because you can see like over the
next two minutes it's just shot up and
then it shot right back down and when it
came back down there was not a lot of
volume so you know if you think well you
know I'm going to have
you know I'm going to
have a offer up here it doesn't get
filled and you're trying to chase it you
chase it chase it chase it you chase it
right back down.
That's that's why you know you you
should have realistic targets in in
thinner markets because you know it may
get up to your target and not quite hit
it. Um let's see if there's any other
trades another trade right here. It's
about 9:00 this morning.
Um is exhaustion print here. You know
you're getting long right in here. This
is around 69 or 70
and it shoots again right back up above
700 before it reverses back down. So you
know
that's what's interesting about this
mini Dow market is you get these pops
and they can happen very fast right?
You're talking one two three four
minutes and then it comes right back
down. So, that's why, you know, it's not
a market to screw around in with in the
sense of well, you know, I'm going to
try and finesse it the way you would do
in, you know, a market like um
E-minis or or bonds.
And just after the cash open, now this
one happened, where is it? Right here.
Again, this is right on the cash opening
time.
8:30.
You can see the volume jumps from 600 to
2,000. Not necessarily a traded area
you'd want to be trading at. Um
and then you got another one came in
right here a couple minutes later, 8:33.
Me personally, I'd I'd rather let the
market settle down rather than try to
take this trade cuz the problem with
this trade, even though it did work out,
right? You're talking a move from 750,
it gets all the way up to I mean, it
makes a 100-point move all the way up to
850, but realistically, you should be
getting out somewhere around 810 for
about uh 50 points, 50 ticks.
Is the amount of risk that you're
taking. Okay? And, you know, your stop
is just below the low coming in around,
you know, double O or O1. It gets down
to about O4. So, it gets within three
ticks of your stop, four ticks of your
stop before making that move.
Okay? But, again, you're you're getting
you're risking about 50 points, 50
ticks, more or less, maybe you know,
plus your stop, so maybe 52.
You know, to get you know, maybe you
don't even get one to one out of this
trade. You know, which is fine. It's
it's nothing to
be upset about, but
you know, I I would just prefer, you
know, the
have a tighter stop in the sense that
the reason you're going to have a
tighter stop is because the market
is already open and trading and you
don't have that sort of influx of orders
that were sort of pent up um starting
since Friday afternoon to be executed.
All right? So, you know, hopefully
you guys can see the importance of
looking at other markets besides
you know, just your normal markets. Just
have them up on your
have a chart up there and keep an eye on
it. Now, just you know, really quick
again and you know what I also recommend
to traders is also have a have a
different chart type open.
You know, again, if there's nothing
happening on the 1-minute e-mini chart,
you know, maybe there's going to be
something happening on the 10 range
chart. And I'm not saying flip around
through different charts. Keep them
open. Even though I just flipped there,
I do have it
I have it open over here, the 10 range
anyway. But, you know, just just keep it
open. And I can see there were some
signals that came in earlier. Again,
this is a buy signal.
These are some trades right ahead of the
cash open. This is right as the cash was
opening, 8:30.
Um
There's a bearish signal up here. It
happened at 7:44 if you if you're
interested in taking it. And it's it's a
move from about 46
you know, down into the 30s.
So, a decent move. But again, you know,
you have to have that chart open and and
be looking at it
to be able to take advantage of it. But
since
since the cash open, even on the eight
range or sorry, the 10 range chart, um
no signals.
So, man, it's still early in the day.
It's only about 10:30 in the morning.
Hopefully, some things will come in that
will drive the market a little bit
later. All right, everyone. Take care.